earlier this week we reported on Pete
Hines Bethesda's VP of PR and marketing
and his completely trustworthy sick note
that fans have fallout 4 could use to
get the day off work looks like people
took Pete up on his offer because on the
day of its release around half a million
people were playing the game
simultaneously shortly after its release
at the stroke of midnight on Tuesday the
tenth of November fallout 4 amass more
than 290,000 concurrent players on Steam
a figure which surpassed Bethesda's
previous record set by Skyrim in 2011
Skyrim's record was later smashed by GTA
5 which peaked at 360,000 players
earlier this year but later that evening
on launch day Bethesda's open-world epic
went on to bring in more than four
hundred and forty-five thousand players
simultaneously setting a new record for
non valve games on the platform valve
still holds the all-time record for
concurrent players with dota 2 at 1.26
million and second place to with counter
strike global offensive at eight hundred
and twenty thousand that's quite a way
to go if you've managed to tear yourself
away from the game to watch this video
or if you're counting down the seconds
at work until you get to play it again
let me know in the comments all come and
find me on Twitter at how not to draw
I'm Kate and war never changes